she don't feel like no pinch feel like
somebody digging a needle into yours
again the rest of them no hurt like that
it's just my head cuz it's like your
skull
you don't really know me right now I
[Music]
never really thought that deeper bodies
especially nothing to get a tattoo
it's just tattoos I got grant how I
shine I'm on and then after that I got
my little sister's name first I got red
night and then I got my other lucious
tonight right here I got a lot of tattoo
I only know how many tattoos I got when
I got this 20 when I was with layer
there's my brother Larry
that was my first face tattoo but he
died so I when he got r.i.p Larry around
between the winter it's r.i.p on top and
Larry on the bottom you know when he got
blocked boy right here then I got deaf
will focus on the right and then my
other look right at a man died and I got
the night tattoo right here dad that's
just [ __ ] we came up with like a secret
meaning that came nobody really know
about my home she's got all bunch of
[ __ ] on my face like everybody else just
gonna put anything
if it's on my face is deep anywhere else
that's different on my face it gotta
stand for something I got a lair I got
Tomiko that's lair mom she got killed
when he got killed and then I got Johnny
B that's my brother he got killed when I
got shot and then I got like the Angels
issue cloud nine ain't religious is just
[ __ ] it look cool my head that was bad
the worst when it hurt bad
I feel like somebody digging a needling
you over know she don't feel like no
kinky the rest of them no hurt like that
it's just I hate cuz it's like school
did I really know meat right now so
that's why that prior to her like that
yeah my favorite part is Glock that I
got on my hip
my favorite point there's like a clock
with a spindle hang another I got shot
in this arm so I can't eat that tattoo
it's gonna hurt because I got like nerve
damage out of tattoo that I got on this
ornate Oh since I've been getting new
tattoos I just do it on this horn that's
why this arm for this aren't you I got a
jinx tattoo I got bullet holes tattoo
right here before I got shot
and then I got shot any on so I feel
like I changed my stuff you know tat no
bullet holes on did you [ __ ] around here
pop this is like juvenile [ __ ] [ __ ] big
ugly ass tattoos where I just was just
letting people do [ __ ] tattoos are like
art you know you look at a painting
sometime gonna be uglier but it's art
tattoos tell your life story it all like
remind me of a time like what was going
on in my life at that point in time
right I got laugh now cry later I got
bloody right here I got school to gun I
got a Ferrari symbol a Bentley symbol a
Maybach something and I got RIPT man and
then I got right here to say don't judge
my story based on the chapter you walked
in on I likes doing here I don't really
watch family guys just like the way
Stewie look though big eyes hey I got
misunderstood and I got played dirty
then I got baby Jason and baby Freddy I
like what they represent but I don't
really like to watch horrible then I got
da songs to represent he's dead lung I
got Satan or run sweet dreams sharp and
then I got the baby from Bebe's kids the
little baby used to ride on the bike I
got him right here then I got home
slaughter games all got a family tattoo
I ever touch alive regards in enough
I ain't just gonna go to my riding
around I'm gonna go get my back a song
all right when I get off until mrs. gear
like all bunch of faces and stories and
[ __ ] people that I looked friends family
a couple of times people I was just yeah
whatever I think of at that moment in
time that's what's gonna happen
asking me if I know that damn tattoo